- Wait.
- That says I have.
- Fuck.
(upbeat music)
- We're identical twins,
and today we're playing Never Have I Ever.
- Never have I ever
pretended to be my twin.
- I definitely have.
- Have.
- Yeah.
- When I first started
dating my boyfriend,
she would like go up to
him and start dancing.
- Yeah, and I was like
pretending to be her.
- And then like it got close
and she's like, "Oh no."
- I was like "No, I'm the wrong twin."
- We were in the same class
and we're like, let's just switch.
It was band class.
- We can't play each other's instruments.
- Yeah I play the drums,
And she plays the saxophone
- And I play the saxophone.
- And so we like sat down,
and like we're getting ready for warmup
and then we like look back
at each other, and we're like
- "Oh crap!"
- Never have I ever pretended
to like or dislike something
just because my twin liked or disliked it.
- Maybe.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- I think it's pretty natural.
- Definite I have.
- I have, totally.
- Because you picked
your major based on it.
- Part of me was like,
"Oh, we'll be closer,"
and then they put you
in the same dorm, like-
- And Mom was like "You can
do the study abroad together,"
and you're like "Alright, I like it."
- Hell yeah.
(both laughing)
- Never have I ever
pretended I was a triplet.
- Have we?
- I feel like we have,
when we were younger.
- That's really funny.
I really wanna know who has.
- This is kind of weird,
but we'd pretend that
we had, like, a triplet.
We always say, like I feel like,
we were supposed to be triplets.
- We think we were a triplet,
and we have like a boy.
- The fraternal triplet.
- Never have I never used a pic of my twin
for my dating profile
implying that it's me.
- I have not with a dating profile,
but if you count,
I was getting Benny for
his birthday a fake ID,
and I took a photo of me.
- We do--
- We share a Raya, yeah.
- If you showed a picture
of you I'd be like
"Oh he actually really just likes you"
Never have I ever said
I'm the smarter twin
- But I am the smarter twin
- Girl you say all the time
See she says it all the time.
- Cuz I am.
- I never say it.
It's so mean.
- Yes you do.
Because maybe you know that it's not true.
- Obviously (laughs)
We do that all the time.
- We do that all the time.
- Well I am.
- Yeah it's just this thing, like:
"Never have I ever"
I always say it.
I certainly did better on the SAT.
- Never have I ever said I'm
prettier or more handsome twin.
- I mean again, it's true.
- But I think you're beautiful.
- Aw you too.
- No we definitely have not.
- No.
- You know like guys will
flirt with you and say:
"You're the prettier twin"
Be like okay well now I have to kill you.
- Yeah I hate you now.
She's way prettier.
- Never have I ever kissed
my twin's significant other.
- I have not.
- I dunno.
- I would never want to.
- We're good people.
- We have kissed the same guy.
- We've kissed the same
guy but you weren't dating.
- Yeah.
- Wanna share?
- Right?
- Like if they're gonna
kiss anyone else it's
Gonna be her.
- Gonna be her.
It's like fun.
- It's like--
- Keep it in the family.
- Never have I ever blamed
my twin for something I did.
- Every day.
- Every time.
- You should do have not.
- Oh I have sorry.
- I wish I had not.
- I can't even think of
a specific moment but--
- I can't even think but always.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- I've definitely said
to mom that you did it
when I was the culprit.
- That's so rude.
- Never have I ever wished
I was an only child.
- Definitely not.
- No never.
- The thought of it scares me.
- It's the best thing in the world.
- I think no right.
- Aww that's so sweet.
- I would not survive.
- I don't know how to be alone.
- No I don't either.
- That sounds more like have I wished that
this person didn't exist and
that's just not the case.
- Yeah so I have not and I won't.
- Never have I ever had
a threesome with my twin.
- No and people--
- That says I have.
- Fuck, no and people ask us all the time.
- No we would never do that.
- That was supposed to say this.
- Holy shit that would be the
grossest thing in the world.
- That is the nastiest thing.
- No.
- I mean I wouldn't be like opposed.
- Did we learn anything about each other?
- Did we have any different answers?
- Have not learned much more about Jack.
- I haven't imagined
anything ever coming up
that we'd be shocked about.
- We already know
everything about each other.
- Yeah.
- No surprises.
- I have had a great time today.
- I have also had a great time today.